a joker care beaucoup de jeunes
t'ont découvert à travers ton dernier album
et chantent mon coeur mais avant de parler
de ton nouvel album j'aimerais que tu
nous parles de ta légende qui fait partie
de la grande légende du rock and roll
tu vas bien  oui mais je vais bien
je ne sais pas c'est très difficile de résumer
euh ta vie en tu sais quelques
essayons  et comment êtes-vous entré en contact
avec le rock and roll bien à cette époque
il y a comme un à sheffield il y avait une
assez grande scène de pub
vous savez nous avions l'habitude de jouer l'éditeur
régulièrement ouais vous savez juste pour assez d'
argent pour vous savez avoir  quelques
verres et juste s'amuser
mais je veux dire que c'était comme une ambition je
voulais juste faire des disques et puis
en 63 j'ai sorti un disque j'ai comme
un contrat d'enregistrement avec
decca d'une couverture des beatles appelée je vais pleurer à la
place  ouais personne ne le sait parce que
tout le monde pense que tu es le premier  euh le disque
était euh avec un peu d'aide de mes
amis qui c'était alcoa à la place
donc c'était cinq ans plus tard je veux dire j'ai
finalement eu un accord ouais mais à ce moment-
là c'était tu sais que j'avais le seul disque
qui n'a pas fait  eh bien et puis comme mon
père l'a dit, vous savez, revenez à ouais en
faisant un travail dont vous vous souvenez en mesurant avec
euh avec euh avec euh jimmy page et les
oiseaux de la cour suivante maintenant c'était réussi c'est un
euh ça a juste gratté dans le top 50
ouais en Angleterre  mais c'était quelque chose
que nous savions que nous allions commencer ouais
et puis nous avons enregistré avec un peu d'aide
ouais parce que tu as fait un festival au festival de
sunbury très vrai et tu as chanté
avec un peu d'aide de mes amis
et c'était très réussi et tu as enregistré
ça et tu t'es placé en haut
des charts maintenant c'est vrai que le
numéro un en Angleterre a très
bien fait ouais c'était une reprise tu as fait beaucoup de
reprises dans ta vie pas vrai c'est vrai
tu n'es pas un auteur-compositeur tu penses que je
je  J'ai essayé et je continue d'essayer  tu
sais que j'en ai un nouveau sur l'album mais
c'est euh je ne sais pas j'ai toujours été
capable de réorganiser les
trucs des autres et tu préfères que je ne
préfère pas nécessairement je tu sais mais je veux dire
j'ai  eu plus de succès en faisant ça en 1969
tu as fait un autre concert très très célèbre
c'était woodstock tu sais
oui euh ça
semble rester dans l'esprit de beaucoup de gens
ouais
quel est ton meilleur souvenir de woodstock euh
juste le tu sais le survoler en
hélicoptère  ouais et regardant vers le bas au lieu
de
la plus grande foule que j'aie jamais vue et
depuis
lors, tu as rencontré leon russell et tu as
décidé de faire de
Mad Dog un anglais ouais ouais vraiment
je veux dire que c'était comme je l'ai dit j'ai eu
le groupe la graisse  groupe et
j'avais l'impression que musicalement nous avions fait tout ce que nous
pouvions avec ouais mais ensuite le euh
c'était assez épuisant un peu le canard fou et l'
anglais était quelque chose de très célèbre et de
très étrange c'était 40 personnes
ensemble pendant 40 jours je suis  Je vais dire que je
ne pense pas que quelque chose comme ça ait jamais été
c'est fait ouais nous avons des chiens sur scène et des
enfants des enfants qui
prennent beaucoup de drogue aussi maintenant
pas les enfants mais ouais
mais je veux dire je pense ouais c'était des
temps stupides peut-être que les
gens disent que cette fois où leon
russell t'a manipulé penses-tu que
c'est vrai  euh je sais que j'ai souvent tu sais que les
gens ont dit ça à propos de leon et je
pense qu'il y avait un peu d'ego
tu sais en quelque sorte là-bas
mais euh tu sais que je l'ai juste pris comme
partie du jeu tu te connais  je l'ai
rencontré à nouveau après qu'il soit encore en
tournée de temps en temps aux États-Unis, mais pas
à grande échelle, vous savez et je ne l'ai pas
vu depuis environ 10 ans, peut-être
qu'en 1972, vous êtes retourné à Sheffield ouais
parce que peut-être que vous en avez pris trop  drogue tu
voulais revoir ton pays ta
mère
et toi tu
as retravaillé avec le chrétien alors
tu sais bien je l'ai fait en fait avec c'est à
peu près quand nous nous sommes séparés nous avons organisé cette
dernière tournée avec les chris state
north all-stars
et puis  euh
tu sais encore que je
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé j'ai
gagné beaucoup d'argent et puis j'ai fini par le donner
aux managers ouais tu étais obligé de
donner la moitié de ton argent à ton manager
maintenant ouais j'étais juste foutu à l'
époque c'est beaucoup d'argent  c'était environ
un point milliard de cents équipes c'est
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent mais
facile pour moi d'y aller mais pourquoi pourquoi
as-tu été obligé de lui donner autant d'argent
j'étais dans un assez mauvais état j'ai
pris tu voulais faire  le problème est
résolu et ensuite pour être
juste libre je pense ouais je n'ai jamais vraiment
pensé aux conséquences que
ta petite amie t'a laissé à ce moment-là
maintenant ouais
tu as été avec elle jusqu'à ce que tu c'est
pourquoi elle était cette chérie d'enfance
ouais tu en sais beaucoup sur moi  terry
vraiment
donc je vais choisir de ah tu sais que nous
savons tout sur les choses
donc c'est vrai je veux dire tu sais que je
n'ai pas vu l'irlande non plus depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant
ouais alors tu es allé à new york et tu as
quitté le terrain mais toi  commencé à boire
beaucoup maintenant ouais c'est vrai je veux dire je ne  t
je ne sais pas quel est le pire des
deux maux vraiment j'aime toujours boire un verre
bien que de
temps en temps mais je veux dire
pas dans la mesure où je veux dire
vous savez si vous avez déjà vu des gens entrer
dans cet état où vous venez de  Je veux dire que
tu sais que toute ta vie dépend de l'
alcool et que
tu ne sais pas que ce n'est pas un endroit amusant mais
tu as dit toi-même qu'à cette époque à
New York tu te comportais ouais comme un
clochard est-ce vrai
euh j'ai peur alors juste  à propos de juste
s'écraser sur des
canapés partout tu sais que ce n'est pas une
belle vie à la fin ça t'épuise
tu sais quel a été le pire moment de
cette période je me souviens d'un gars
qui m'a dit à quel point j'avais été sur scène
un soir et j'ai refusé  le croire
et puis il m'a passé une cassette et il était
si mauvais que ouais je me suis réveillé et j'ai pensé que
je ne pouvais plus faire ça ouais quand
tu es venu quand tu es venu en france à
casterly ouais en 1976
tu n'étais même pas capable  pour chanter sur scène
je me souviens que
je suis désolé pour ces jours mais j'espère
qu'ils n'arriveront pas
on pardonne  Je t'aime parce que nous t'aimons
alors jen t'a beaucoup découvert en 1990 elle
t'a donné une maison à los angeles c'est
vrai ouais c'est là que j'ai rencontré ma femme
ouais
ma femme actuelle eh bien ma seule femme en
1982 tu as fait un disque avec un chris
blackwell qui est l'un de vos meilleurs
disques il s'appelait le chef steel
ouais disque très étrange
j'étais reconnaissant parce que j'ai fait un
album avant celui que euh appelé le luxe
peut se permettre n'a pas très bien marché
et donc c'était vous savez ireland records
ouais et euh c'était à peu près chris comme
une sorte d'idée pour obtenir euh
euh wally badaru ouais et
donc c'est un peu une sorte de disque culte
je trouve ça parce que ça
n'a pas bien marché particulièrement en termes de ventes
autour  le monde mais c'est en quelque sorte c'est
très connu bonne renommée ouais ouais
et puis il y a eu un miracle encore tu
as fait son duo
il est devenu numéro un tu as mis la
bande originale de l'officier et du gentleman
correct oui oui
donc c'était euh
le plus je veux dire que c'était  étrange parce que
je n'ai jamais eu de numéro un
Aux États-Unis, c'était un peu étrange de le faire de cette
façon, vous savez, mais
ce n'était pas bon pour la renommée du rock and roll
ouais, je vais dire que le genre de
personnes qui viennent aux spectacles ne sont pas les
mêmes qui aiment frapper  tu sais ce truc
et puis sur chat my heart en 1987
c'est beaucoup de succès combien d'albums
as-tu vendu jusqu'à maintenant euh en
fait cet album nous en avons fait environ deux
millions dans le monde aussi ce qui est
bien tu sais que c'est un 45 ans  ouais d'
accord
et ton nouvel album alors parlons-
en ouais une nuit de péché ouais qui est
euh l'air je ne me souviens pas de l'
air d'elvis presley une nuit ouais une nuit
qui voudrais-tu
c'est le même air mais c'est les paroles originales d'
un gars  appelé smiley louis
un homme de blues de j'oublie chicago a
écrit et donc c'est une interprétation un peu différente
apparemment elvis quand ne pouvait pas euh
faire les mots originaux de ils pensaient que ce
serait mauvais pour son image à l'époque
vous savez
et j'ai fait un  co comme vous le dites, vous savez que je
fais les refontes ou quoi que ce soit ouais un
version de fièvre ouais tu sais
et bien sûr la chanson que je fais
aujourd'hui de brian adams quand la nuit
vient et brian est dans la vidéo il est venu
et a joué sur la session c'est un gentil
garçon quels musiciens euh euh
très proches du dernier album  avec tm
stevens ouais phil grande à la guitare mais
chris stanton est de retour avec moi sur celui-ci
oui toujours là encore bien en arrière oui
il travaillait avec eric clapton ouais alors
il faisait un truc musical euh
donc c'est tu sais
j'espère que tu l'aimes quand même nous  comme ça,
nous avons déjà les bandes
[Musique]
bleu